-Making her TV debut, performing "Persuasive" and "Crazy,"
give it up for Doechii!
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Insects chirping, birds calling ]
-♪ Ooh-ooh-ooh-ooh ♪
-Ladies and gentlemen, I am Doechii.
And this is the band and brothers.
♪ If it's weed on sight, then it's all okay ♪
♪ Mood's alright if we all gettin' paid ♪
♪ Socks on thigh, and we all too high ♪
♪ To be not okay, to be not okay ♪
♪ All night long, goin' all ♪ -♪ Damn day ♪
-♪ 9-9 holes, bae, all them... ♪
♪ Sun gonna shine, and they all gonna grind ♪
♪ Till they all get fined and they all get ♪
-♪ Shady ♪
-♪ All of them persuaded you to be my baby ♪
♪ Weezy Weed, F Baby ♪
♪ And the "F" is for ♪ -♪ Faded ♪
-♪ Got lines like gators, and we so flirtatious ♪
♪ And she so persuasive, face or flee ♪
-♪ She's so persuasive ♪ -♪ Hah! ♪
-♪ That marijuana ♪ -♪ Hah! ♪
-♪ She's so flirtatious ♪
♪ How does it feel to be you? ♪
♪ She's so persuasive ♪ -♪ Hah! ♪
-♪ That marijuana ♪ -♪ Hah! ♪
-♪ She's so flirtatious ♪
-Let's go, y'all! -♪ How does it feel to be you? ♪
-♪ How does it feel to be that, that chick? ♪
♪ How does it feel to be that, that rich? ♪
♪ How does it feel to be that, that, chick? ♪
♪ How does it feel to let, let, let go? ♪
♪ She's so persuasive ♪
♪ That marijuana ♪
♪ She's so flirtatious ♪
-♪ How does it feel to be you? ♪
-♪ So persuasive ♪
♪ That marijuana ♪
♪ She's so persuasive ♪
-♪ How does it feel to be ♪♪
[ Segue into "Crazy" ]
-♪ Huh, huh ♪
♪ Huh, huh ♪
♪ Huh, yah ♪
♪♪
♪ Y'all calling me crazy ♪
♪ When I been, been ballin' all day like Brady ♪
♪ Long hair this wavy ♪
♪ And I been, been shopping all day, no Macy's ♪
♪ How 'bout first lady? ♪
♪ You...can't date me, look at your savings ♪
♪ You...still waiting ♪
♪ Still blowing out daisies, counting on daydreams ♪
-♪ Crazy, got 'em going crazy ♪
♪ None of these hating... gonna faze me ♪
♪ Crazy, got 'em going crazy ♪
-♪ Huh, huh ♪
-♪ None of these... gonna faze me ♪
-♪ Huh, yah ♪
-♪ I got 'em goin' crazy ♪
-♪ Then I ball like Spalding ♪
♪ Can't call my bluff when the...is my calling ♪
♪ Won't duck...I'm all-in ♪
♪ It's a brand-new day, new pace, light jogging ♪
♪ Straight facts, no... ♪
♪ It's a whole lot of big blue ♪
♪ Low stress, no stallin' ♪
♪ See a whole lot of big... when I fall in ♪
-♪ I'm going crazy, yeah, you can't date me, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings, yeah, got 'em going crazy, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings ♪ -♪ Can't date me ♪
-♪ I'm going crazy, yeah, you can't date me, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings, yeah, got 'em going crazy, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings, ...can't date me ♪
-♪ Gassed like a Texaco ♪
♪ Offshore like a Mexico ♪
♪ And if a...unsure, I can letcha know ♪
♪ I'm gonna stick to the point like a decimal ♪
-♪ And that's cuckoo nuts, crazy, amazing ♪
♪ Bookoo bucks...you pay me ♪
♪ Awful luxury...saved me ♪
♪ Who knew you'd go...crazy?! ♪
-♪ Crazy, got 'em going crazy ♪
♪ None of these hating... gonna faze me ♪
-Let's go! -♪ Crazy, got 'em going crazy ♪
-Make some noise for Jimmy Fallon. Hah!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Hah!
-♪ Go crazy ♪ -♪ Hah ♪
♪ Hah ♪
-♪ Going crazy ♪
-♪ Number-one crazy, yeah, they pay me, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings, yeah ♪
♪ Got 'em going crazy, yeah, look at your savings ♪
♪ Got 'em going crazy, yeah, you can't date me, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings, can't date me ♪
-♪ Got 'em going crazy, yeah, you can't date me, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings, yeah, got 'em going crazy, yeah ♪
♪ Look at your savings ♪
-[ Shouting ]
♪ Look at your savings, can't date me ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]